VENUS WILLIAMS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOOD NIGHT.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE ARE LIVE FROM SOUTH KOREA.
JUST BEHIND US IS THE DMZ.
THAT'S THE BARRIER THAT
SEPARATES THIS COUNTRY SOUTH
KOREA FROM THE DICTATORSHIP FROM
NORTH KOREA RUN BY KIM JONG-UN.
WE WILL HAVE AN INTERVIEW IN A
FEW HOMOSEXUALITY.
-- MOMENTS.
THE PRESIDENT INVITED US TO COME
WITH HIM HERE TO THE MOST
HEAVILY DEFENDED BORDER AND WE
WITNESSED HISTORY.
THE PRESIDENT HELD A MEETING
WITH KIM JONG-UN.
THE FIRST AMERICAN PRESIDENT TO
SET FOOT IN NORTH KOREA.
HE WALKED WITH KIM ALONE ACROSS
THE BORDER.
WE STOOD A FEW FEET AWAY AND
WALKED BACK AND HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE STANDING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROOM.
WE WERE THERE.
IT HAS IMPLICATIONS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE BROAD THAN JUST THE
PICTURES.
THE PRESIDENT HAD A SUMMIT WITH
KIM IN HANOI THAT COLLAPSED AND
HIS EFFORTS TO DENUCLEARIZATION
NORTH KOREA WERE DEAD.
THOSE HOPES MAY BE REVIVED.
IT WAS A REMARKABLE SCENE AND WE
HAVE PICTURES WE TOOK THERE.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: BEHIND ME ARE TWO
COUNTRIES THAT COULD NOT BE MORE
DIFFERENT.
ON THE LEFT IS SOUTH KOREA.
YOU CAN SEE THE FLAG FLYING.
TO THE RIGHT LESS THAN HALF A
MILE IS NORTH KOREA.
YOU CAN IT THERE.
THE RED AND THE BLUE FLAG.
THAT VILLAGE RIGHT BEHIND MY
RIGHT SHOULDER IS FAKE.
THERE ARE NO INHABITANTS THERE
AND NO FLOOR IN THE BUILDINGS.
IT'S A PROPAGANDA VILLAGE TO
SHOW THE STANDARD OF LIVING IN
NORTH IS HIGH.
NO ONE IS FOOLED BY.
IT YOU ARE REALLY RIGHT HERE
LOOKING AT THE GREATEST DIVIDE
ON PLANET EARTH.
ON THE LEFT ONE OF THE RICHEST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
ON THE RIGHT THE POOREST.
>> [WHIRRING].
>> WE ARE TAKING THIS LIVE ON TV
RIGHT NOW.
IS THAT OKAY?
>> Tucker: STANDING ON THE NORTH
KOREA BORDER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WITH THE SOUTH KOREA PRESIDENT
ABOUT TO MEET WITH THE NORTH
KOREA LEADER.
NORTH KOREA SECURITY BEHIND ME.
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
COME ON!
GUYS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, HOW DO YOU
FEEL?
>> I FEEL GREAT.
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE.
>> THIS IS AN EXPRESSION OF HIS
WILLINGNESS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS
UNBELIEVABLE.
SORRY, I GOT TO WATCH THIS.
>> IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR THE
WORLD AND AN HONOR FOR ME TO BE
HERE.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS MIND
BLOWING!
THE PRESIDENT WALKS ACROSS WITH
KIM JONG-UN.
STOOD RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STREET.
ALMOST NO ONE AROUND AS YOU CAN
SEE.
THE FAMOUS BLUE HOUSES.
KIM WAS VISIBLY WINDED FROM THE
PROBABLY 20 YARD WALK.
LOOKED BEWILDERED.
A LOT OF CAMERAS GO OFF IN HIS
FACE.
WE WERE 4 FEET AWAY FROM HIM.
HE SEEMED OUT OF HIS ELEMENT.
I FEEL LIKE SOMETHING AMAZING
JUST HAPPENED.
SOMETHING JUST HAPPENED WITH
SECURITY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM THERE.
APPEARS TO BE MILITARY LEADER
AND PARTY LEADERS AND A LOT OF
BODY GUARDS.
SOME ARE REALLY AGGRESSIVE.
A COUPLE WENT AFTER SOME
AMERICAN JOURNALISTS.
OUR SECRET SERVICE RESPONDED
DRAMATICALLY AND THERE WAS A
SCUFFLE IN VERY TIGHT QUARTERS
ON THE WAY IN TO THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN TRUMP AND
KIM.
SO KIM JUST WALKED BACK INTO HIS
COUNTRY.
THESE ARE THE NORTH KOREA
SECURITY GUARDS.
THEY DON'T LIKE BEING FILMED.
ALSO TRAVELLING WITH KIM WAS A
PRETTY LARGE CONTINGENT OF
PHOTOGRAPHS AND CAMERAMAN.
KIM STOOD RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN CAMERAMAN.
OUR SECRET SERVICE TRIED TO PUSH
THEM BACK AND THIS MAN RIGHT